COMPLICATED FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
BOTH RUSSIA AND CHINA HAVE BEEN
TWO SECURITY SOURCES TELL
ROYALTIERS THE RUSSIANS HAVE
SCIENCE PROFESSOR IN SAN
FRANCISCO.
IMPRESSIVE VOTE.
THE SANCTIONS WHAT WOULD YOU
RECOMMEND TO THE PRESIDENT?
>> WHAT IS HAPPENING HERE IS
AND BECAUSE THE RUSSIANS AND
CHINESE ARE NOT LIVING UP TO
UNITED NATION'S SECURITY COUNCIL
RESOLUTIONS THE ONE IN
SEPTEMBER, THEY ARE VIOLATING
INTERNATIONAL LAW AND NORMS.
I WOULD SIGNATURE PRESIDENT OF
THE UNITED STATES MAKE IT
ABSOLUTELY CLEAR THAT IF THE
GOVERNMENT RUSSIA AND CHINA
DON'T PENALIZE AND STOP THOSE
SHIPPING CUTCHES THAT ARE
OPTION S
OPTION
OPTIONS AND THE FACT THAT THE
UNITED STATES WILL BECOME THE
LEAD
LEA
LEADER OF RESOLVING THE CONFLICT
WITHIN ASIA AND BEYOND.
I THINK RUSSIANS AND CHINESE
WANT TO HAPPEN
>> NOW TO ADD TO CLARITY YOU ARE
SEEKING MITT OPTION WITH RUSSIA
AND CHINA ARE NOT VIABLE THEY
CAN DO A NAVAL BLOCKADE IS WHAT
WHAT YOU MEAN BY TAKING MILITARY
ACTION?
>> I'M NOT SUGGESTING MILITARY
ACTION BALL BECAUSE I KNOW THE
SECRETARY OF STATE AND THE
SECRETARY OF DEFENSE DO NOT WANT
TO GO DOWN THAT PATH.
THEY HAVE BEEN WORKING OVER TIME
ON THE DIPLOMATIC FRONT.
WE HAVE TO LET OUR ADVERSARIES
IN THE NORTH KOREA ISSUE
WE WILL CONDITION TO SUZ
DIPLOMACY BUT THEY HAVE TO KNOW
PROP ITTING UP.
JOT PRESIDENT IS TRYING TO
CHANNEL REAGAN IN THE PEACE
THROUGH STRENGTH APPROACH.
IS THE UNITED NATION S
IS THE UNITED NATION
IS THE UNITED NATIONS
IS THE UNITED NATIONS -
IS THE UNITED NATIONS --
IS THE UNITED NATIONS -- I
IS THE UNITED NATIONS -- I W
IS THE UNITED NATIONS -- I WOU
IS THE UNITED NATIONS -- I WOULD
NOT SAY IT IS WORTHLESS IT IS A
HUGE DEBATE IN SOCIETYUNE THE
GENERAL ASSEMBLY OF THE UNITED
STATES IS THE TARGET.
SUGGESTS THAT THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY IS MOVING IN THE
DIRECTION OF WHAT THE UNITED
STATES HAS BEEN SAYING ALL ALONG
ESPECIALLY UNDER PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THAT NORTH KOREA HAS TO BE A DE
DANGEROUS.
IT COULD BE THE SITE OF NUCLEAR
PROLIFERATION THROUGHOUT
NOW UNDER THE AMERICA FIRST
POLICY OF THE PRESIDENT IS HELP
REENFORCE THE ISSUES THAT
AMERICA FIRST AND PRINCIPLED
REALISM PILLAR OF THE
PRESIDENT'S POLICY SUGGESTS THAT
SOVEREIGNTY MATTERS.
RESPECTING INTERNATIONAL NORMS
AND LAW MATTER AS WELL.
IN THAT WAY THE UN PLAYS A
USEFUL ROLE
>> MY OWN TAKE ON THIS IS MORE
SANCTIONS WILL NOT WORK THE
LEADER OF NORTH KOREA DOES NOT
THINGS NEEDED IN CRITICAL IN
NORTH KOREA IS A VIABLE THING ON
THE PRESIDENT'S DESK.
>> I THINK IT IS BEING DEBATED
IN THE PENTAGON AND NATIONAL
SECURITY.
WEATHER IT IS ON THE PRESIDENT'S
DESK, I DON'T KNOW.
I WILL SPEAK TO YOUR PESSIMISM
COMPLIANCE.
AND IF GIVEN THE STRICT NATURE
OF THE DECEMBER RESOLUTION
IS IMPLEMENTED FULLY IT HAS A
PUNISHING IMPACT ON NORTH KOREA
RUSSIANS AND CHINESE IF THEY
DON'T COMPLOY THEY ARE UNDER
MINING SOMETHING THAT COULD
BRING NORTH KOREA TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE.
>> I HOPE PRESIDENT TRUMP
CONDITIONS TO SHOW THE WORLD HOW
THE RUSSIANS AND CHINESE ARE NOT
COMPLYING SOMETHING THEY WERE